[Music]
you guys the midterm elections were on
Tuesday and the results were full of
surprises John fetterman beat Dr Oz in
Pennsylvania
that lady who used to yell at the Press
is now the governor of Arkansas
the Georgia Senate race is so close they
can't call it which means that later
this year there will be a runoff between
Democrat Rafael Warnock and Republican
Herschel Walker hey you again
no it's Herschel Walker again it's
Herschel Walker again dude I just said
that why are you here to celebrate I won
a senate chair even despite massive
voter frogs
you mean voter fraud
you say potato I say Chicago
you did not win you still have to beat
Rafael Warnock in a runoff
he's not beating me in the runoff I
played professional footballs
well you're not gonna physically run
against him then why do they call it a
race think about it
I cannot believe you are this stupid no
what you can't believe is that red wave
that hit y'all on Tuesday we surfed in
on it like we were one of the [ __ ] boys
The Who
the the [ __ ] boys you know they they
sing the song smurfing USA you mean
Surfing USA hey you say tomato I say
Colorado Herschel there was no Red Wave
Republicans did way worse than predicted
even congresswoman Lauren bobert is in
an unexpectedly close race it was rigged
oh no she's here
this election was rigged why Lauren
because it was close
exactly how could this race possibly be
close people love me ever ever since I
sent this actual real life Christmas
card
that photo sucks
well then you're really not gonna like
my Valentine's Day card
buddy I don't know how to tell you this
but everybody hates you
well if that's true they should have
told me I mean if only there was some
way for people to tell an elected
official that you're not happy with the
job they're doing there is it's called
an election and we just had one hey
you leave Lauren yogurt alone
Lauren go-kart
who Humphrey Bogart ah you guys gotta
get out of here fine by me I have to get
ready to be the great state of Georgia's
next Minotaur
Senator you say potato I say Demi Lovato
gross you two are almost as bad as
Marjorie Taylor green I can't believe
she won this week thank God she's not
here to gloat about it or is she
foreign
no one can smell what you're cooking
because I assume everything you cook is
terrible it is I like it that way you
wanted me to lose
316 says I just whooped your ass you
guys need to get out of here right now
Lord bobert Herschel Walker and Marjorie
Taylor green everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]